♪ ♪ ♪
- Une vieille enseigne
et un décor familier sur
le boulevard Saint-Laurent.
Une devanture qui n'a pas changé
depuis 50 ans, qui fait partie
de l'histoire de la "Main".
La boucherie-charcuterie
Slovenia, fondée par deux
frères slovènes, va disparaitre.
JEAN TEIXEIRA, propriétaire,
Boucherie-charcuterie Slovenia
- Si on ferme, c'est
parce qu'il y a demes,
il y a des problèmes, il y a
des problèmes...
- De pandémie, ou...?
- Oui, c'est ça, il y a un peu
de tout là, un peu de tout là...
- À qurs de
la fermeture, les tablettes
sont dégarnies. Reste encore
quelques pots de choucroute
et de poivrons. Mais il y a
eaucoup de saucissons et
de produits d'Europe de l'Est.
Un vieux comptoir
qui en a vu des factures,
avec sur le mur, une page
encadrée d'un calendrier
de 1933 de l'Association
des bouchers de Montréal.
On sent la tristesse ici.
L'atmosphère est chargée,
et une dernière poignée de main
de la part d'un livreur.
- Reposez-vous.
- Merci.
- Un jambonnot?
- Oui.
- De vieux clients
qui se souviennent.
- Pour la choucroute, bien sûr,
mais aussi pour la boucherie.
Une boucherie exceptionnelle
.
- Mais là, c'est dommage.
- C'est très dommage, oui.
- Très triste. Moi, je suis
arrivé d'Europe en 73.
J'ai découvert Slovenia
parce que, moi, je viens
de l'ex-e.
C'est pour ça que j'achète
pour la dernière fois.
- Qu'adviendra-t-il de
ce commerce?  Et bien,
le propriétaire a refusé
de nous répondre, se contentant.
- C'est triste, mais
je leur souhaite la meilleure
des chances. Puis on verra,
peut-être que quelqu'un va
le prendre et puis continuer
les traditions, j'espère.
- Monsieur Teixeira,
en tout cas, lui, s'en va.
- Je vais prendre ma pension.
- Des vacances?
- Bien oui, c'est ça.
Je pense que je l'
J'ai gagné assez déjà
depuis 50 ans.
- Une retraite bien méritée.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada, Mon